thank everybody they voted for me they
didn't tell me how many people were
nominated so I'm not sure how happy I
should be about thank you Joe and
everybody at Glamour I want to just
clarify a few things while I'm up here
as Sigourney has left but seriously we
are not the same person she has very
generously signed my name a number of
times and I have taken credit for a lien
I don't know why this happens but we are
in the same general vicinity if you saw
us at the table you can see this is not
true we are two separate people secondly
Elizabeth Felix will not forgive you he
will not forget either he will talk to
his shrink and a number of people about
this incident I'm sure it's just the
beginning of many things you will miss
because you are following your heart and
your passion but since he's in your
family I'm sure he will become an artist
and use it in some way later and one day
when he falls in love with a woman or a
man or a trans man or a trans woman
exactly he will he will give them the
support and the respect because he's had
a mom who's great and who is following
her passion also I would like to go on
record as the oldest of nine children to
say no one unfortunately did go down on
my mother I'm almost positive
and she is 93 and it doesn't look like
it's gonna happen also by the way Rose
Byrne and I have a film that's coming
out and she was great in that film so
you left that out it's called the
meddler and she does steal every scene
but luckily she's not in the entire
thing with me so I got a few back but
she is [ __ ] brilliant and I would
also like to say that you know this is I
have never been to an award show where
people have said content [ __ ] [ __ ] so
often and I really want to thank you
because when I look at this that's what
I'm gonna remember and I all my awards
are in what we call the famous bathroom
and this will go in there with the Oscar
and all the other ones thank you
inspiration is a funny thing I mean you
often don't even know when you've
inspired somebody you know you have an
act of kindness or generosity or just
basic survival and you can find out
later that you know it meant somebody to
somebody and so my only advice would be
to be as kind and generous and authentic
as you possibly can be we mentioned
Greece and I have to say I just didn't I
am inspired by women I mean women guys
I'm sorry but nobody multitasks like
women
as my son said when he was about four he
said when I was doing step mommy said
but you can't die you're the glue mom
and I think that you know what we have
to do is stop worrying about being
perfect and do the best we can and
remember to have the most fun you can
and in terms of all this inequality of
you know how many roles how much we get
paid yada yada yada I hope that women
can remember that it's not quantity but
quality the counts and who wants to play
all those parts anyways some of those
guys parts suck I hope that everybody in
this room that is connected and somehow
to any kind of art form can men too can
do some things tell some story that they
care about tell that story somehow
whether it's film or TV or columns I
love that you said about being kind and
in a column and because really that's
what's important is to find something
that really triggers something some
flame in you that that you can then
share with somebody and even if it takes
I work for Stanley I don't know how long
it took you to get that movie up that we
did that you cared so much about you
know that's that's really what you want
to do is find those little kernels of
things that will inspire people but
aren't necessarily going to be as huge
as Elizabeth's movie was but that you
have a good time doing it and that you
can tell so many stories are not just
about white heterosexual males of a
certain age and and nothing against
those stories but there are a lot of
other stories and they can be made and
they can be written and they can be
painted and they can be sung and
I as I started to say you know going to
lesbos and seeing what's going on there
and how those women are struggling to
keep their families together and all the
crises that are in this world today this
is the heartfelt boring part there are
many many faces that need to be seen and
many many stories that need to be told
to humanize some of the things that are
going on right now and so if any of them
catch your fancy then I would say that's
great because we do learn so much by
what we see and what we hear and we have
a great opportunity to empower so many
women and young men and change their
idea of how things are done and what is
important and what can give you pleasure
and and to laugh at ourselves and I
think we are at a tipping point now and
we really need those things so if
everybody goes home now and just jot
down something they want to do or say or
reach out and tell any kind of story
about any people making connections that
is the bravest thing that you could
possibly do I thank